[Aplausos]
[Música]
estamos todos de acuerdo los últimos
años están siendo una auténtica locura
básicamente desde que empezó el año 2020
hemos vivido una pandemia la guerra más
grande en Europa desde la Segunda Guerra
Mundial una crisis energética y la
inflación más alta en varias décadas
vamos que igual no llega a ser la época
más interesante de todos los tiempos
como dirían más pero desde luego no está
dejando indiferente a casi nadie y por
si esto fuera poco Parece que la vieja
dinámica de bloques ha revivido algunos
incluso dicen que la Guerra Fría está
regresando Solo que esta vez el
principal contrincante de los Estados
Unidos no es la unión soviética sino la
República Popular de China y mis
queridos amigos de visualpolitik si hay
algo que se toma muy pero que muy en
serio En Washington no es otra cosa que
la seguridad Nacional de esta forma en
la estrategia de seguridad nacional que
la administración biden publicó en el
año 2022 no dudaron en señalar
directamente a lo que consideran sus dos
grandes amenazas China y Rusia estos
competidores creen erróneamente que la
democracia es más débil que la
autocracia porque no comprenden que
poder de una nación surge de su pueblo
Estados Unidos es fuerte en el exterior
porque somos fuertes en casa nuestra
economía es dinámica nuestra gente es
resiliente y creativa nuestro ejército
sigue siendo incomparable y así seguirá
siéndolo presidente Joe biden en la
estrategia de seguridad Nacional de 2022
Pero esto es el siglo XXI y pese a lo
que estamos viendo en Ucrania hoy en día
las amenazas ya no vienen solamente en
forma de guerras convencionales
la ciberseguridad y el uso de la
Inteligencia artificial también se están
convirtiendo en dos grandes prioridades
para las agencias de la seguridad
nacional y eso ni siquiera es todo en lo
que llevamos de siglo el uso de la
guerra comercial y económica también
está adquiriendo cada vez más
importancia y por eso y para completar
una serie de vídeos que hemos empezado
aquí en visualpolitik sobre la situación
de la seguridad de los Estados Unidos
podéis ver todos los enlaces en la
descripción nos hemos hecho esta vez
unas cuantas preguntas Cuáles son las
grandes amenazas a las que se enfrenta
hoy por hoy los Estados Unidos como de
peligrosa es la rivalidad norteamericana
con China y Rusia como estos países
están intentando debilitar tanto
económica como militarmente a la gran
potencia norteamericana son las amenazas
externas las únicas a las que se
enfrenta El Tío Sam hoy vamos a
responder a estas preguntas pero antes
vamos a ver un poco de historia
[Música]
las nuevas formas de la guerra
creo que en esto no hay ninguna duda
todos sabemos que el ejército de los
Estados Unidos es con muchísima
diferencia el más poderoso de todo el
mundo pero imaginad por un momento que
Estados Unidos y China comenzaran de
repente una guerra total por tierra mar
y aire bombardeos aéreos batallas
navales misiles ciberataques creéis que
en un escenario así china tendría más
éxito que el cosechado por Rusia en
Ucrania Pues lo más probable es que sí A
diferencia del país de Putin china es
una superpotencia industrial y también
en cierto modo tecnológica también es un
país mucho más grande y con muchos más
recursos Y quizá por eso china se está
modernizando mucho más rápido que Rusia
siendo ya la segunda gran potencia
económica del mundo tan solo por detrás
de los Estados Unidos China tiene
capacidad de sobra para mejorar su
armamento y sus capacidades militares
una buena prueba de ello es la
presentación del portaaviones cnsfuyang
el tercer y más avanzado portaaviones
que ha producido y que en ciertos Campos
compite directamente con el más avanzado
de los Estados Unidos el uss gerald Ford
por ejemplo en el uso de catapultas
electromagnéticas
como os podéis imaginar los nuevos
portaaviones que está construyendo china
reforzarán su dominio marítimo en toda
la región sin embargo esto es tan solo
la punta del iceberg ya que este país
también Está realizando fuertes
inversiones En la producción de misiles
hipersónicos misiles seis veces más
rápidos que los cazas f-35 americanos no
obstante su inversión en el ciberespacio
lo que más está llamando la atención de
hecho según braison el 95% de todo el
ciber espionaje que sufree Estados
Unidos proviene precisamente de China
[Música]
y por eso no es raro que de vez en
cuando nos encontremos con noticias como
estas 25 de mayo de 2023 según la
inteligencia occidental hacker chinos
espían infraestructuras críticas de
Estados Unidos 24 de mayo de 2023 los
piratas informáticos chinos que atacan a
Estados Unidos y One pretenden
interrumpir las comunicaciones según
Microsoft oam se ha convertido en un
centro estratégico cada vez más
importante para Estados Unidos 2 de
octubre de 2022 según un análisis y su
grupo chino de piratas ataca a agencias
y empresas de Estados Unidos y ha
incrementado su actividad en realidad la
mayor amenaza a la que ahora mismo se
está enfrentando los Estados Unidos por
parte de otros estados son los
ciberataques pero ojo no solo hablamos
de China Rusia por ejemplo tampoco se
queda corta de hecho en febrero de 2022
Estados Unidos expulsó a 12 oficiales de
la misión rusa en la ONU por haber
estado llevando a cabo operaciones de
espionaje y ciber espionaje sin embargo
la preocupación de los Estados Unidos
también se extiende a una opción que
Putin ha puesto sobre la mesa durante su
invasión de Ucrania el uso de armas
nucleares
ya todos sabemos que Rusia es la mayor
potencia nuclear del mundo y que china
está muy cerca de superar a la India
Pakistán y Corea del norte Sin embargo
Estados Unidos tiene los ojos puestos en
otro actor fijaos en esta noticia Irán
nuclear los inspectores de la
organización Internacional de la energía
atómica hayan partículas de uranio
enriquecido al 83,7% Exacto mis queridos
amigos de visualpolitik No creo que
ninguno se vaya a sorprender si os digo
que al Tío Sam le preocupa Irán el país
de los ayatolas está consiguiendo
enriquecer uranio hasta niveles muy
próximos a lo que se necesita para
desarrollar armas nucleares Y eso es
algo que podría crear un inmenso caos en
Oriente medio Israel Arabia saudí
Turquía Prácticamente todo el mundo se
volvería loco en esta región si
finalmente los atolas se hicieran con la
bomba el riesgo sería demasiado alto y
el régimen iraní sería Intocable Incluso
en lo que respecta al estrecho de ormuz
que ya sabéis que es por donde pasa gran
parte del petróleo que consumen países
como Corea del Sur Japón o la propia
Taiwán pero ahora os voy a hacer una
pregunta de quién es Aliado Irán 321
exacto
así que tenemos a China a Rusia a Irán
la guerra convencional la guerra híbrida
y los ciberataques todos ellos son
riesgos relativamente nuevos que se han
creado o que han vuelto a crecer en las
últimas dos décadas y la pregunta es
ante todo esto que está haciendo Estados
Unidos Pues como no podía ser de otra
forma no se van a quedar con los brazos
cruzados Y esto es lo que explica
noticias como esta vaiden prepara el
mayor presupuesto de la historia para el
pentágono mientras avecinan recortes de
gasto no lo dudéis el tío Samba a pisar
el acelerador va a seguir gastando
cantidades ingentes de dinero para
intentar seguir siendo muy superior a
todos sus adversarios en todos los
frentes
[Música]
con todos los ciberataques que sufre la
administración biden ha hecho de la
ciberseguridad un Pilar central por eso
el ejército de Estados Unidos ya
desplegado varios equipos encargados de
la ciberseguridad y también equipos para
llevar a cabo sus propios ciberataques
Así mismo con el desarrollo tecnológico
especialmente de China el pentágono está
reforzando su apuesta y destinando miles
y miles de millones de dólares a la
robótica la Inteligencia artificial la
tecnología láser y el desarrollo de
sistemas de ataque y defensa
hipersónicos por ejemplo en los últimos
años la logic Martin ha instalado el
sistema helios en todos los destructores
de la marina americana es decir que
Estados Unidos ya cuenta en su flota con
armas láser capaces de derribar aviones
y hundir barcos en otras palabras
estamos presenciando los problemas de
una nueva carrera militar
[Música]
Claro que esta que hemos visto es la
parte de las amenazas más digamos
convencional pero estamos en pleno Siglo
21 y si algo hemos aprendido es que
estas no son las únicas amenazas que
existen a nivel internacional podemos
encontrar muchísimas más posibilidades y
una de las que están sonando últimamente
es precisamente esta
[Música]
el Imperio del dólar en apuros
todos recordamos a Joe biden decir que
convertiría a Rusia en un party
internacional después de que invadir
Ucrania y lo decía en serio las ancianas
que impuso junto a la Unión Europea han
hecho que muchos países del Mundo ya no
estén tan Seguros A la hora de
relacionarse con Rusia por miedo a
sufrir sanciones económicas Pero por
supuesto Rusia haya encontrado un socio
que en cierto modo le cubre sus espaldas
china atrás quedaron las viejas disputas
de la Guerra Fría hoy China y Rusia
mantienen una sólida relación que se
extiende desde el campo militar hasta la
energía las finanzas y el comercio Sin
embargo a excepción de la energía de las
relaciones más bien desigual Por ejemplo
mientras los productos chinos suponen un
18% de todo lo que importa Rusia los
productos rusos apenas representan el 2%
de lo que china importa del resto del
mundo pero desde luego Esta no es la
única simetría entre ambos países
atentos
efectivamente mis queridos amigos de
visualpolitik desde que se pusieron en
marcha las sanciones que impidan a Rusia
comerciar fácilmente con dólares o euros
Rusia ha hecho del yuan su principal
moneda para las transacciones
internacionales y no solo eso también se
ha convertido en su principal moneda de
reserva Pero esto no debería sorprender
a nadie Al fin y al cabo ambos países
forman parte de la Organización de
cooperación de Shanghai y han estado
impulsando al comercio con monedas
locales en lugar de con dólares pero no
sólo eso en 2015 Rusia y China también
suscribieron una alianza financiera que
reforzaba esta misma idea de hecho
aunque algunos grandes bancos chinos han
dejado de relacionarse con Rusia por
miedo a violar las sanciones
internacionales los pequeños y medianos
no están haciendo lo mismo por eso Rusia
ha podido esquivar en cierta forma
algunas de las principales sanciones
económicas por ejemplo usando
infraestructuras de pago alternativas
para superar el bloqueo s muchos de sus
bancos con todo No es extraño que Putin
diga cosas como esta estamos a favor de
usar el Joan chino para los pagos Entre
Rusia y los países de Asia África y
América Latina Putin después de su
reunión de primavera con sillín en 2023
ahora bien depender del yuan también
tiene muchos problemas os hemos hablado
de ello en un reciente vídeo que tenéis
en la descripción cambiar el control de
Washington por el de Pekín tampoco
parece la mejor idea del mundo y por eso
desde Rusia se ha barajado otra
posibilidad crear una moneda para los
brics
[Música]
por si alguno no se acuerda el término
brick se refiere a las siglas de las 5
grandes economías emergentes Brasil
Rusia India China y Sudáfrica entre
ellos suponen casi la mitad de la
población mundial y una quinta parte del
pib global con semejantes números no
parece descabellado pensar que pudieran
crear una moneda capaz de competir con
el dólar ya no solo es que ellos lo
utilizaran es que otros países también
la podrían adoptar para el comercio
internacional y así poco a poco podría
crearse una enorme red de operaciones en
la moneda de los brics Por ejemplo si
Tailandia tiene que empezar a usar esta
moneda para comerciar con China desde
Brasil podrían seguir comprando
productos tailandeses sin tener que usar
otra moneda diferente porque a Tailandia
también le vendría bien cobrar en esta
divisa y la pregunta es pero todo esto
para qué Pues básicamente para acabar
con El dominio del dólar reducir los
capitales internacionales que terminan
en Estados Unidos y de paso impedir que
Washington pueda aprovechar su posición
para aplicar sanciones económicas a
diestro y siniestro ahora bien tampoco
nos volvamos locos el dólar es demasiado
fuerte y seamos honestos quién se fiaría
de una moneda dirigida por países como
Rusia o China y además hay otra pregunta
de verdad creéis que podrían ponerse de
acuerdo sobre quién manda y quién la
gestiona no parece que sea una tarea
fácil y sea como sea no lo dudéis el
dólar mantendría el grueso de su
influencia en la economía mundial Y
diréis por qué Pues ya os lo hemos
explicado con todo detalle a quien
visualpolitik podéis echar un vistazo al
vídeo que lo hemos dejado en la
descripción por ahora en este vídeo lo
único que queríamos era poner sobre la
mesa otra amenaza en la que los
adversarios de Estados Unidos ya están
trabajando Este es otro de los grandes
riesgos contra la seguridad nacional a
los que se enfrenta El Tío Sam riesgos
para los que hoy por hoy Parece estar
bastante bien cubierto pero ya sé lo que
os estaréis preguntando alguno solo hay
riesgos externos Y si tuvieran las
propias entrañas americanas algún
parásito dispuesto a causarles mucho
daño alguna idea de lo que estamos
hablando pues atentos
una gran fractura local
[Música]
mis queridos amigos de visualpolitik
Estados Unidos es un país con muchas
fortalezas pero también con muchísimos
problemas no dejamos de verlos por todas
partes la inseguridad en muchas ciudades
el abuso de drogas como el fentanilo
muchísimos reclusos una altísima
población sin techo y muchos otros más
hablamos de problemas que están
provocando una importante fractura
social Pero por encima de todos ellos
hay un enorme problema que muchos
analistas empiezan a señalar como el más
peligroso de todos la enorme
polarización política y social habéis
oído bien cada vez más la política en
Estados Unidos ya no se centra
únicamente en asuntos de gestión como
impuestos o las armas o la sanidad sino
que ahora las identidades han tomado
también el espacio político la división
de la sociedad por raza etnia género o
ideología ha cobrado muchísima fuerza
dicho de otra forma el tribalismo se ha
extendido por la política americana y la
polarización sigue profundizándose cada
vez más creéis que exagero pues fijaos
lo que piensan los propios americanos ya
lo veis más del 60% de los
estadounidenses dicen que la división y
la vigilancia política aumentarán en los
próximos años y siendo en estos es muy
probable que vaya a ser así desde 2016
la sociedad estadounidense se ha partido
prácticamente en dos la inclusión en la
política de una de las figuras más
controvertidas ha hecho Mella en la
estabilidad social y muchos ya sabréis
de quién estamos hablando Donald Trump
la situación ha llegado hasta tal punto
que incluso Los Americanos tienden a ser
muy pesimistas tanto como para decir
esto más del 40% de los estadounidenses
cree probable una guerra civil en una
década a ver lógicamente no parece muy
razonable pensar en una guerra civil al
uso pero todo esto sí que podría
terminar paralizando o incluso
colapsando muchas de las instituciones
del país Por qué Muy simple la
polarización lleva que las alianzas
políticas sean más difíciles de lograr y
las negociaciones estanquen más
fácilmente y sabéis que precisamente por
esto el mensaje de reelección que
publicó el mismísimo Joe biden a finales
de abril de este año no se centran las
amenazas externas sino en la gran
amenaza interna que representa la
polarización de la sociedad pero seamos
honestos tampoco es un mensaje
especialmente conciliador de hecho
señala los republicanos y no duda en
acusarles de manera indirecta del
recorte de derechos y libertades del
país en fin que Estados Unidos se
enfrenta a nuevos retos pero
curiosamente los más peligrosos de todos
pueden ser los que tiene dentro de casa
ahora bien llegados hasta aquí turno
para vosotros creéis de verdad que
Estados Unidos llegará a tener otra
guerra civil crearán al final los brics
su propia divisa esta moneda podría
desplazar realmente al Dólar logrará
china superar a Estados Unidos
militarmente podéis dejarme vuestra
respuesta en los comentarios y como
siempre no olvidéis Que aquí en
visualpolitik sacamos vídeos nuevos
Todas las semanas así que suscribíos a
este canal y dadle a la campanita para
no perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones si os ha gustado este
vídeo dadle a like y nos vemos en el
próximo un saludo y hasta pronto
[Música]